>> Tucker: SUMMA IN THE LAST
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, JOE BIDEN
GOT 12 MILLION MORE VOTES THAN
BARACK OBAMA.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
WHILE TODAY THE LATEST
JANUARY 6TH HEARING, LIZ CHENEY
OF WYOMING EXPLAINS SHUT UP.
SAY A WORD ABOUT MAIL IN
BALLOTING AND YOU'RE A.
WATCH.
>> THE PRESIDENT UNDERSTOOD EVEN
BEFORE THE ELECTION THAT MANY
BIDEN VOTERS VOTED BY MAIL
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP IGNORED
THE ADVICE OF THE CAMPAIGN
EXPERTS AND TOLD HIS SUPPORTERS
ONLY TO VOTE IN PERSON.
>> FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PLAN
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION RELIED
ON A SUSTAINED EFFORT TO DECEIVE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
>> HE BETRAYED THE TRUST OF
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF HE IGNORED THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS AND LIED TO HIS
SUPPORTERS ON THE COUNTRY.
AS A RESULT OF HIS LOSS, HE
DECIDED TO WAIT AND ATTACK ON
OUR DEMOCRACY.
AN ATTACK ON AMERICAN PEOPLE BY
TRYING TO ROB YOU OF OUR VOICE
AND DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: NEW MESSAGE FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHAT'S THE ANSWER?
ASSURES THAT THE LAST ELECTION
WAS ON LEVEL.
NO, THE SHOW IS NOT REASSURING
ANYBODY.
THE WHOLE EFFORT IS AN ATTEMPT
TO PUNISH ANYBODY WHO CHALLENGES
THE REIGNING ORTHODOXY.
RYAN KELLY LEARNED THAT THE HARD
WAY.
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR IN
MICHIGAN.
HE WAS JUST ARRESTED LAST WEEK
BECAUSE HE WAS AT THE CAPITOL
PROTEST ON JANUARY 6TH.
WE WANTED TO TALK TO HIM TONIGHT
AND WE CAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
JUST TO GET THE FACTUAL STUFF
RIGHT OUT, DID YOU COMMIT A
CRIME ON JANUARY 6TH?
>> THERE WAS NO CRIME COMMITTED,
TUCKER.
NO, NEVER ENTERED THE CAPITOL
BUILDING, I EXERCISE MY
FIRST AMENDMENT.
THOSE THAT HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE 2020 ELECTION RESULTS, THEY
WANT TO INTIMIDATE AND THREATEN
US.
NOT JUST ME, BUT MY FAMILY,
SUPPORTERS AS WELL.
>> Tucker: THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T TYPICALLY ARREST LEADING
CANDIDATES AND GUBERNATORIAL
RACES UNLESS THEY HAVE YOU ON
VIDEO TAKING CASH AND PUTTING IT
IN YOUR FREEZER OR SOMETHING.
WERE YOU SURPRISED THAT FEDERAL
AGENTS SHOWED UP AT YOUR HOME?
>> IT WAS DEFINITELY A SURPRISE.
I THINK THE NARRATIVE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN PUSHING
BECAUSE OF THEIR FAVORED
POLICIES IN REGARD TO ENERGY AND
IN REGARD TO ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT MATTER TO AMERICANS, WE SEE
THIS CONTINUE THE LEFT WING
AGENDA BEING PUSHED.
THE JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE, I
THINK A LOT OF AMERICANS SEE
RIGHT THROUGH THIS.
IF THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT
DEMOCRATS ARE UP TO.
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL TO THEM.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO DO TO
ACTUALLY DO THE THINGS THAT ARE
AFFECTING THEIR DAY-TO-DAY LIFE
TO BRING SOLUTIONS TO OUR STATE
AND COUNTRY.
WE SEE JUST THE CONTINUATION OF
THE LEFT PUSHING FURTHER LEFT
AND COMMON SENSE, REGIONAL
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF STEPPING UP
TO MAKE SURE WE SAVE OUR STATE
AND COUNTRY.
BRING RELIEF TO AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
>> Tucker: BUT ARRESTING
PEOPLE SEEMS LIKE A BRAND-NEW
FRONTIER IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
FROM WHAT I CAN TELL, YOU
WEREN'T DOING ANYTHING
DIFFERENT.
YOU'RE DOING THINGS THAT LESS
CRIMINAL THAN MANY OTHERS
STANDING WHERE YOU WERE
STANDING.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S POLITICAL
MOTIVE HERE IN ARRESTING YOU AS
A CANDIDATE?
>> ABSOLUTELY A POLITICAL
MOTIVE.
JUST 12 HOURS BEFORE I WAS
ARRESTED, JOE BIDEN WAS ON
JIMMY KIMMEL SAYING THAT HE'S
GOING TO ARREST HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
THERE IS NO COINCIDENCE IN THE
TIMING OF THIS.
IT'S RIGHT ALIGNING WITH HIS
POLITICAL THEATER THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING.
THERE IS NO COINCIDENCE HERE.
AT SOME OF THE POLLS ARE SHOWING
I'M WINNING.
THE SUPPORT HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS
AND WE HAVE SEEN NEW POLLS NOW
WHERE MY LEAD HAS GROWN
SUBSTANTIALLY.
I TAKE THAT AS A SIGN OF
GRATITUDE TO MY SUPPORTERS OR
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT THEY HAVE
STEPPED UP AND HELPED WITH.
JUST A REASON FOR ME TO WORK
TWICE AS HARD AND GET MY MESSAGE
OUT THERE SO I CAN SERVE THE
GREAT PEOPLE OF MICHIGAN AS OUR
NEXT GOVERNOR.
>> Tucker: SO YOU'RE RUNNING.
BOLD.
>> YES, SIR.
>> Tucker: AMEN.
RYAN KELLY.
>> WE'RE MOVING FORWARD AND WE
INTEND TO WIN.
WE STILL THERE?
>> Tucker: YEP.
I APPRECIATE IT, THINK HE
APPEARED >> WE INTEND TO WIN ON
2ND OF AUGUST AND AGAI